this is probably one of the most
horrendous crimes i've come across i
used to find myself in the garden in the
middle of the night standing there by
myself throwing and viewers out david
fuller thought he'd got away with it 34
years ago the electrician murdered two
women in tunbridge wells but those
murders were not his only crimes
i had spent
two wonderful hours in the mortuary
um
sleeping with her
and that gave me some sort of comfort
little did i know that my daughter had
been violated
as he finally faces justice the question
remains how could this have happened
pam nell's daughter wendy was just 25
years old when she was found dead by her
boyfriend in her blood-stained bed
she'd been sexually assaulted and
strangled in her bedsit in tunbridge
wells in kent
and this was a picture she asked me to
take
to say that's a picture of starting my
new life
didn't have much of it did she as the
years went by pam believed the person
who killed her daughter would never be
found
it was just the thing that we lived
through
you know
it wasn't something you knew it well
once you go past a year you think oh
well it's never gonna happen
david fuller murdered another woman five
months later the body of caroline pierce
who was just 20 years old was found
lying in a flooded drain
what became known as the bedsip murders
remained unsold for years
but in 2019 thanks to developments in
dna techniques police tracked fuller
down david you're under arrest and
suspicion of the murders of wendy nell
and caroline pierce in 1987.
it's uh
we're all stuck there's
it was during a search of his house that
they discovered fuller had been
recording himself sexually abusing dead
bodies and possessed extreme pornography
they found thousands of videos cds
photographs in total 14 million images
there are evil
sadistic individuals that have come
across and then there's david fuller who
his actions just speak for themselves
he's just there are no words for him
in july 2020 police came to nevra's
kamal's door to tell her that her
daughter had died falling from a bridge
over a year later more officers turned
up they said to me um
to do with azra
and for that moment i'm thinking i said
to them what azra's dead the police had
come to tell neverest that her daughter
was one of fuller's victims in the
hospital morgue
i had spent
two wonderful hours in the mortuary
sleeping with her
and that gave me some sort of comfort
did i know that my daughter had been
violated
prior to that day
and the evening of that day
and there's me kissing and cuddling and
saying my last goodbyes
and that's quite awful
quite awful
fuller has admitted violating nearly 80
dead bodies many of which he filmed but
detectives believe there may have been
hundreds more victims in three decades
he worked at the hospital
david fuller had a swipe card for the
mortuary because he sometimes needed to
do maintenance work there he knew that
staff went home at 4 pm
porters might still visit the receiving
area delivering bodies but the same
fridges had doors opening onto the
post-mortem area where fuller committed
his crimes here there was no cctv until
recently and the fridge doors were
unlocked
fuller gained access through the utility
rooms avoiding cameras but he still
needed to swipe in
he had entered uh
the morgan autopsy area
thousands of times not hundreds but
thousands of times
no one
ever stopped him or asked
what's this guy doing in here he was the
man to go to
he always made himself available to the
mortuary staff they thought that the
perpetrator was a great guy
and basically
he groomed them
he groomed them
they became compliant they never
questioned him
he would actually abuse women while
supporters were bringing in dead bodies
externally and internally
if what he did to azra was his only
crime he would face just two years in
prison a rape charge carries between 4
and 19 years
azra was a friend of mine and helped me
produce some of my reports here at sky
news
her mother believes the best tribute to
her is for lessons to be learned
hospital trust has launched an
independent investigation into whether
anything more could have been done
men and women up and down the country
will be appalled
by what they're listening to
what they've read about
and i remind them
that if this was your loved one
you would roar with rage
and i'm silently
roaring and i'm beseeching
people that make laws
to create a law
that this becomes an offence
and the appropriate sentencing is passed
down we need to respect the dead
yeah
the hospital trust has launched an
investigation into what happened
david fuller has pleaded guilty to his
crimes including double murder
[Music]
you